Ukraine is calling it another kind of
terrorist attacks Russian forces
continue their Onslaught against
critical infrastructure Nationwide
President volodimir zielinski says the
attacks which intensified last week have
destroyed nearly a third of Ukraine's
power stations Kiev is now formally
asking for more robust help from Israel
as NATO rushes to deliver air defense
systems to help intercept the Swarms of
iranian-made drones striking targets far
beyond the front lines in the capital
Kiev and across the country
officials in the southern Ukrainian city
of mikolai pullerman's body from the
rubble
a Russian missile killed him as he hid
in the basement
his shocked neighbor recalls the moment
of impact
we woke up at quarter to two in the
morning because of a very loud explosion
it's impossible to describe so much dust
we were in the basement we crawled out
through openings in the ground
our neighbor died unfortunately he was a
bit closer to the epicenter while we
were a bit farther away
for many ukrainians the past eight
months have been a seemingly endless
series of Horrors
but one resident took comfort and the
belief that his country holds the moral
High Ground no matter how much suffering
Moscow piles on them
the Russians get pleasure from us
feeling bad
they feel pleased
I think they want us to bomb and shell
their buildings and so on
but we won't so we can show that we are
different from them
civilian residences aren't the only
buildings targeted by the Kremlin
Russian forces also seem determined to
knock out the country's energy grid
according to the mayor of the city of
jetamir airstrikes on the power plant
there left 11 settlements without power
while Russia denies deliberately
attacking civilians it says it's
targeting Ukraine's energy
infrastructure
meaning millions could be left to face
the coming winter without heat or power
and I can now welcome James Hodson he's
the co-founder of the economists for
Ukraine group and joins us from Berkeley
California welcome to the day Mr Hudson
large parts of Ukraine's power
infrastructure have been destroyed in a
single week some places are currently
even without water how dangerous is that
for the country
oh thank you Nicole it's great to be
back on on the show now
yeah it's hard to understate how
dangerous it is for a country to lose
this much energy infrastructure in such
a short period of time it's obviously uh
going to put a lot of pressure on the
emergency forces and on the Energy
Services within the country to replace
repair and find Alternatives in in many
places now Ukraine is a country that
gets very cold in the winter it's a
continental climate and cold causes
death cold causes increased illness and
other complications in society
we're going to see businesses and
schools that can't operate even more
than than they have in in the past and
it will also impact areas like food
Logistics which become more fragile Over
time however
I think that the economic angle is is
especially important to to consider in
this case which is that the ukrainians
have been talking for a while about the
need to get people back to the cities
get them back to work get them back to
paying taxes get them back to a normal
life and the biggest reason why these
attacks are happening now is to prevent
that from happening prevent the return
of any kind of stability in corners of
Ukraine that we're getting used to some
semblance of normalcy over the past
couple of months yeah with a third of
power stations affected after a week
doing very simple maths here that means
that Russia could take out the rest in
another two weeks basically is that a
likely scenario
okay so so the nature of energy growth
is a little bit more complex than uh
kind of a linear relationship with uh
removal of these nodes so it's unlikely
that you know if you take out a third in
one week you take out the full amount in
three weeks that's fair very very
resilient it actually I was lucky enough
just four weeks ago to be in Kiev and to
speak with the minister for energy and
Minister for infrastructure and I do
believe that the Ukrainian energy grid
encompassing all different energy
sources and also on that
um under circumstances of last week for
instance selling energy to Europe and in
fact having a long history of selling
excess energy to others I think that the
grid is more resilient than we give it
credit for however what we need to take
into consideration is that these Iranian
drones are cheap and the ukrainians are
shooting them down with expensive web
Western provided missile systems if I
had to guess the Russians are playing
the game of trying to burn down the
supply of Western provided missiles
in order to then take on potentially
much more damaging and broader strikes
that could take out large portions of
energy and other critical infrastructure
with their own dwindling supplies of
guided missiles
and of course it brings up the whole
conversation about the importance of air
defenses and effectively closing the
skies which is what I believe we've been
saying for seven months at this point
uh We've now seen Ukraine formally
asking for help from Israel actually to
boost its air defense capabilities do
you think Israel will get involved in a
more robust way
I it'd be very difficult for me to take
a you know a strong position in terms of
my knowledge of Israel and its and its
history I think it's we'll just have to
wait and see what Israel does in this
situation I think the moral prerogative
at this point clearly states that they
need to be doing more than they have
been doing but the moral prerogative is
often not the one that is most
important when countries are making
decisions unfortunately that is
unfortunately correct
um you know Ukraine very well and you've
come to know it even better throughout
this conflict and over the past eight
months the people of Ukraine have become
masters of rebuilding what Russia
destroys often in a matter of days how
can they go about fixing these vast
damages to the critical infrastructure
presumably you know at times without
power
yeah and of course
um you can't really train for this uh
although the emergency services are
supported also by uh teams across Europe
um the Europeans are doing a fantastic
job also
um enabling kind of the selling of spare
parts and and kind of infrastructure uh
enabling components that can help to
re-enable some of these substations
um but
when you're doing this under
circumstances of continued attack right
it uh it changes the the Dynamics of the
situation now the ukrainians are very
good at creating temporary
infrastructure they're very good at
plugging gaps they've done a fantastic
job interconnecting the infrastructure
more over the past few months which does
make it more resilient I think what we
need to see is the EU us UK and and
others stepping up to ensure that
Ukraine has all of the replacement parts
that it needs that it has the Manpower
that it needs in order to carry out the
emergency repairs and moreover if there
are ways for us to help Ukraine to
protect this new infrastructure and the
repairs that they do that's going to be
extremely important now as I mentioned
when I was in Kiev I I did get to see a
few places around the city and it was
incredible to see the resilience of the
population and how quickly they've been
able to get back on their feet clear the
streets get critical Services running in
two days I went to two different
restaurants that were opened in the last
two months so this is a people that is
definitely not giving up and and that
will continue to uh to innovate and to
develop
James Hodson of economists for Ukraine
there thank you so much Mr Hodson
thank you
and with those concerns over Ukraine's
energy infrastructure we have news from
the investigation into leaks in the
nordstream gas pipeline supplying
Western Europe Danish police now say
those leaks were caused by powerful
explosions which did extensive damage
footage shows at least 50 meters of the
underwater pipeline is missing the case
is being treated as an act of sabotage
today the Kremlin said the investigation
was being tailored to put the blame on
Russia Moscow accuses the west of being
behind the explosions